on peut plus rien dire cette phrase est
agaçante à plein de niveaux différents
et si on en faire le tour rapidement
déjà reconnaissons que le verbe pouvoir
est ici employé comme synonyme de droit
la phrase veut en fait dire on n'a plus
le droit de rien dire
et oui c'est pas une histoire d lopper
donc bon dieu règne
ça semble affirmer qu'il y avait des
trucs qu'on avait le droit de dire qu'on
n'a plus droit de dire le plus énervant
c'est sûrement l'exagération liés aux
morilles un genre la moindre limitation
devient synonyme d'interdiction totale
mais il n'y a pas eu un moment dans
l'histoire on pouvait tout dire sans
même parler de l'époque où un mot de
travers sur la vie pouvait valoir le
bûcher ça fait un moment quand même que
si vous accuser publiquement quelqu un
quelque chose cela peut être considéré
comme de la diffamation
dans un autre genre si vous écrivez une
tribune dans un journal pour appeler au
meurtre d'une catégorie de la population
vous allez avoir des ennuis avec la
justice mais attention on ne peut plus
rien dire ne renvoie pas tellement à la
question légale
ça a plutôt à voir avec les moeurs les
gens qui disent ça ne se plaignent pas
que de nouvelles lois encadrant la
liberté d'expression soit appliquée ils
disent plutôt l'évolution des moeurs
nous empêche de dire ce qu'on veut dire
et parfois ils appellent carrément ça la
dictature du politiquement correct
dictature c'est un peu gonflé parce
qu'en effet ils ont encore entièrement
le droit de dire ce qu'ils veulent dire
simplement ce que ça souffle dans ton
sens savons le faire savoir
donc en fait on peut encore dire tout ce
qu'on pouvait dire avant mais on risque
d'entendre quelques ta gueule henri tôt
donc on ne peut plus rien dire
ça laisse entendre qu'on avait plutôt
bien baliser le champ des trucs qu'on
pouvait dire tranquillou sans faire
particulièrement attention et que tout
d'un coup c'est parti en cacahuète
les gens sont devenus beaucoup trop
susceptible et à cause de ça une forme
de pression empêcherait de dire des
trucs qu'il faudrait avoir le droit de
dire l'idéal du truc non les gens ne
semblent pas tant s'indigner parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas tout dire mais
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus dire
certains trucs et c'est quoi ces trucs
qu'on peut plus dire visiblement c'est
grosso modo les trucs qu'on pourrait
trouver misogyne raciste homophobe
outrance comme c'est parfois ce qu'on
appelle le politiquement incorrect mais
il suffit de rappeler l'existence d'eric
zemmour ou de michel onfray pour se
rassurer on peut visiblement aujourd'hui
encore faire carrière sur des
déclarations politiquement incorrect
ces news invite le génie bastié cyril
hanouna recrute geoffrey lejeune
visiblement le politiquement incorrect
ça ne m'est pas tellement de bâtons dans
les roues de l'ascension professionnelle
mais du coup une question qui se pose
c'est tout simplement pourquoi on se bat
pour le droit de dire quoi ceux qui
lancent y en a marre de la bien pensants
ce qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire au fond
que la mal pensants c'est cool parce que
de l'autre côté nous on a plutôt
l'impression que les discours dangereux
gagne du terrain et on trouve ça
flippant d'où le fait qu on se crispe un
peu parfois
pour rappel les idées peuvent engendrer
la mort
la théorie du grand remplacement
introduite par renaud camus et
popularisée par zemmour a motivé trois
tueries de masse christ church en
nouvelle zélande san diego et el paso
aux états unis des dizaines de personnes
sont mortes parce que des gens ont cru
aux dangers du grand remplacement et
leur peur est alimenté par ses prises de
parole publiques
ce n'est tout de même pas anodin n'est
ce pas normal qu'on appelle à plus de
vigilance et de le côté peut-on vraiment
se battre pour pouvoir exprimer de
telles opinions
je vous laisse là dessus s'est vu